ma perché dimmidove dove cazzo sono ma
dove mi sta portando dove vista ferme
cosa succederà nelle caverne è successo
questo bel ali fantastico dove sono
caduto set ma non è vero ma non è vero
mai ero nelle caverne cosa è uscito
vadano avanti baggins tuo gioco è quello
tutti ragazzi e benvenute che sono video
sono vari j
ed oggi siamo tornati su the forest in
singleplayer vista non lo state
chiedendo lasciamo perdere niente
ragazzi quindi continuiamo da quello che
poi sono uscito quindi continuavano con
la vocalità corda ragazzi siamo legati
al soffitto di una caverna io non so
come sia possibile visto che ero in una
cazzo di cave tanto c'è ancora le
zeppole per camminare fantastico tale
giorno chi si sta comodi in questo hotel
vero devo ho preso lascia quindi posso
liberarmi dal mica pensavo si fosse
tirato una sciatta sui piedi fantastico
giorno fa vj mi avete portato qui perché
sono un figo non la cosa da fare
aggiunta alla lista esplora la caverna
continua ad esplorare la caverna grazie
perché sono scrivere di nuovo non lo
facevo grazie mille ma serio allora che
cazzo di caverne cosa vuoi che esplori
deficiente di un deficiente sono già
uscito tratto quanti oggetti ciò che non
dicono
madonna quanta roba avevo faccio la
pistola è allora il suo rumore
bruttissimo vediamo un paio di cose già
che ci sono magari senza farci ammazzare
senza fare i pirla ove dico a farmi
prendere un po di lasciate chiama un po
di lasciate a queste cose ho una puntata
di the forest che riesco a fare qualcosa
incredix un ragazzo in segnatevi questo
momento salve roth i pantaloni da de
fonseca fatto le valigie come l'hanno
portate le valigie giu ecco dove vanno a
finire le valigie quelle che perdi dall
aeroporto
ho sempre chiesto io per me dovete
togliere però ragazzino idee pozzo sta
qua tutta la vita a importunare cadaveri
salve e poi ci ha proprio una bella cera
ragazzi ho trovato non è vero c'è la
mappa delle caverne ma mi si vede che mi
si muovo fantastico allora che solo in
teoria con tutta sta merda che ciò
nell'inventario dovrei uscire avrò
trovato la mappa della caverna e non
posso assolutamente perdere questa
occasione quindi andiamo avanti che
meglio adatto dove recupera un po di
vita sono schiatto fatemi recupero e
così a barretta di cioccolata è un bel
the alla fresca mi carica sono più
attrezzato qua che a casa mia
qualche a trovare ho fatto solo un
pezzettino quante grossa st caverna
vedesse si mette male torno indietro che
vedevo di permesso torniamo pure
indietro ragazzi porca di quella l'altra
[ __ ] via via vedere mi sono
incastrato pure vorrei salire e non a
spese fashion come si guarda usiamo la
sua pistola di merda una volta nella
vita
appello del 6 gratis e nascosto 20 fra
the theory sparare in bocca e mi
dispiace però andata così oggi che non
ri di più è brutto [ __ ] o ragazzi mi
dispiace perché è un bravo ragazzo alla
fine si vedeva però non è che posso sta
qui a far sopravvivere tutti che non
hanno piano piano piano piano piano
non ho capito no vi prego no tutti
tranne lui lo odio l'odio e vabbè mica
stanza in sincronia salve e non la senti
io mi faccio i cazzi miei tutti i cazzi
tuoi nessuno e rompe le balle qui quali
quella ladra via via [ __ ] avanti
siete il fuoco dai fuoco dai fuoco
veloce dal fuoco
ti deve bruciare tutta la famiglia su
sky vedi che si è bruciata la famiglia
no no scherza lo scalo scherzavo
scherzavo perché successo che salto
incredibile acrobatico ti è piaciuto ho
fatto un salto veramente di merda
sono rimasto aggrappato alla faccia per
un'ora e mezza oro saltarlo io ma chi
cazzo proprio ma io sai che ti dico
[ __ ] co lo uccido perché non è
possibile che nella vita in onestà
uccidere un di sti stronzi che avete da
una vita e mezza che vado avanti a
tentare di uccidere edifici non ci sono
mai riuscito nota ammazzo
eccolo eccolo ma muori male non craftare
di 2 miliardi di moto poi ce la farò e
prima o poi per me lo sento io è che il
boss del gioco ce la farà batterlo per
ricreare male
porca la [ __ ] sì sì o come brucia il
co 20 brucia il fratello ma non è vero
regalo fai il figlio adesso è mai
peccato il nostro amico qui che ha
smesso di fare il film solo perchè gli
ho fatto un culo così devi morire anche
no non è successo non è fottutamente
successo cosa vi fa pensare che sia
successo veramente questa cosa non lo so
ma non è successo e seriamente e morto
era morto come minchia fatto uccidermi
se è morto e capisci va bè ragazzi e io
non ho veramente parole ma vi giuro non
voglio neanche sapere quello che succede
pavimenti e come se non avessi fatto
niente complimenti grande favi ottima
idea quella di saltare sui cadaveri
delle persone morte
sempre che quello sia una persona
ragazzi sentite sapete che vi dico che
me ne vado a prescindere me ne vado
dalla vita avevo già miss a sul deretano
sta qua sotto a prescindere quindi
usciamo che bello perché per che avevate
una caverna dentro una tenda arga temi
l'utilità di mettere a gara ma cos'è che
non piove dentro e adesso io faccio un
rifugio qui ma po qua nella base dei
nemici la faccio questa è un'ottima idea
così che salvo la partita così che se io
muoio riparto direttamente da qua e sono
già dentro la caverna perché tanto
ragazzi mio figlio sarà sicuramente ma
sicuro là dentro sicurissimo e va a fan
cuore non buttare giù gli alberi però mi
chiama mi sono dimenticato di dirvi una
roba piccolissima ragazzi con un
problemino se muoio anche stavolta qui
ho perso c'è nel senso ho perso tutto
tutti gli oggetti tutte le case devo
rifarmi tutto daccapo quindi vedo
non morire che è meglio perfetto allora
fatemi recuperare vita mi sono fatto 18
molotov cioè seriamente se non vinco
stavolta upgrade weapons veramente posso
rendere le mie armi più forti che non
avevo idea e quindi hanno attaccato un
dente attaccate un dente allarme allora
serve cerchiamoci l'orologio ci siamo
ragazzi non ho capito come dei denti
possano migliorare la potenza di
quest'arma però lo aveva salvato la
partita vi sono bello carico e posso
andare a fare il cu li con la mia palla
da tennis giochiamo a tennis cerbiatto
salve giochiamo a tennis
mangio chiama tennis ragazzi io me la
darei a gambe ma velocissimo dove devi
muovere il culo dove diavolo è finita la
caverna dove la caverna dove la chiave
andare a quattro è finita la caverna dio
mio mi viene a prendere name is gancia
la corda mentre scendo michea sarebbe
tragico una paura matta vai scendi
veloce a dovremmo riuscire magari non a
uccidere il tizio perché devo trovare il
bambino ho tutte le carte in regola
senza neanche usa la corda voglio salto
tutte le carte in regola per vincere
ragazzi ce la posso fare meno sento i
parà il tipo quando lo uccido neanche
gola la torcia lo vado vogue di ascea
stronzo con la torcia sicura avete
capito perché lacca senso forti studenti
pratical kiver ancora non ho capito cosa
serve questo giornalino però mi scusi se
lo importunata una seconda volta non
volevo ha poi c'è la foto dello yacht
che il giugno dell 82 la seconda quant'è
che stai quasi giusto quei 30 anni che
sei rimasto incastrato da sotto che ti
hanno cambiato la vita qualcosa qua per
forza qua per forza eccolo eccolo sto
fatto fuori una volta brutto ed
efficiente tra i fatti farò fuori di
nuovo fuori allo ragazzi di molotov di
molotov 10 non preparando preparati
tutte madonna come l'ho scampata 1 dai è
vero perché non lo accetta sono un
deficiente sentiti io ce l'ha fatta è
saltato un bambino addosso se devi
morire saltando ti tocca stavolta non ti
tocco di mortacci sua devo far fuori
anche i figli
madonna quanto tolgono i bambini sono
più forti e figli dalla madre via via
via via veloce via via via subito
ops offre l'esclusivo non ci credo mai
l'orologio ha già per dare il tempo non
è vero ora devo provare la bomba auto
suscito a creare una bomba a caso so
manco io come ho fatto a farlo lega pro
va bene ma sapete che vi dico
ma crepate guardi esplori esplode slavi
veloce i vostri fanno v ma a tutti i fan
bum bum bella li ragazzi queste sono 20
st l'unica canzoncina che sentirete
nella vostra vita inutile ragazzi ha
fatto saltare tutti i mostriciattoli a
caso troppa roba in un episodio sorgano
incredibile eh si come adesso sono
capito che posso fare i cui usciamo
perché fatemi capire dove si esce di
quanto è stato difficile resa veramente
un casino però solo fatto il bello è che
adesso che ho scoperto
sì ma non t'ha lontana e non era così in
alto prima
no no non è vero non è vero
ragazzi non è possibile non ci voglio
fare non è possibile non è non è poco ma
dai ma perché ho schiacciato il tasto
per lasciarmi li mortacci mia o dio sto
male ho trovato la vera questa l'uscita
di prima ci scommetto quello che volete
era questa state pensando a quello che
sto pensando io muori male
non è morto non importa non è morto
[ __ ] a questo gioco di ma non solo
loro sono parte lo sopporto pensavo di
essere morto per sono morto
non sono morto non so se si è capito ma
non sono morto ok e io era tavolo non so
io non faccio ucciderlo e uscire però
non è morto problema è questo ma ce la
fai
mikati ha lanciato un esplosivo una
volta che lo uccido e sopravviva santo
gesù di grande episodio per far star o
ciso 3 vol 3 3 non l'avevo mai ucciso da
quando ho iniziato le foreste ucciso tre
volte in un episodio è una volta sola
sono riuscita a sopravvivere grazie a
dio dai fan host a casa così ma pure
rialzata serio mica 103 ma quando li
trovo tutti i bronchi allora che ho
deciso mi piazzo la casetta qua così a
me non so cosa fare posso farmi più o
meno l'idea di come mi deve venire
villaggio famose sto recinto inutile che
dopo circonda la casa
la serie che se superano il muro tipo
l'attacco dei giganti non riescono
comunque entrare in casa perché ciò la
casa rialzata però non lo supereranno
mai il muro perché io sono troppo forte
l'unico problema adesso è trovare la
legna perché per farsi così serve
leggermente un po di ledoux disboscare
tutta la foresta è una cosa indecente
ragazzi tagliare tutti si alberi che fa
ho io con gli alberi non sono fortunato
e quindi lo sto attento sapete che
mandata bene che fece uscito un piccione
dall'albero mazzi che sta a vedere cosa
fanno i piccioni nell'albero facevo io
non so fortunatissimo quei tronchi
d'albero e se capace che tirando nessuno
mi distruggo tutta la casa così stupore
o no no no no no no oggi hai capito ma
lo zio
no no io c'ho dei denti sull'ascia ma
sei scemo ma come pensi di vincere
sufficiente a viveur life a salve era
tuo marito questo da come ha reagito mi
sa che era suo marito
se siete deficienti non è colpa mia io
non vi darei neanche fastidio sede voi
perché c'è una lattina di fanta
nell'anno spiegate mela sta cosa va beh
no no no no no no suo carico la
recinzione neanche koharu spari salvini
potete spodestarli brutti stronzi
ma che fatica che dai però da pian piano
ce la stanno facendo incredibile
calcolano ragazzi conclude episodio di
the forest
mi è piaciuto ragazzi conti ma non è il
prossimo dove cerco di fare il villaggio
e mi sto divertendo veramente tanto
perché una volta che cerchi di costruire
le cose tue diventa veramente figo cosa
siete ragazzi se vi è piaciuto lasciato
commento è un mi piace anche a facendo i
facebook come pilota bene scrizione
senza vestiti scateni ci vediamo al
prossimo video e ragazzi